is represented by this
tensor product right here.
All of this generalizes
to any number of systems and we'll see some additional examples when we turn to the quantum setting, which works in exactly the same way
except that we have unitary matrices rather than stochastic matrices, and that's enough about
classical information for now.
Now we'll turn our attention
to quantum information and how it works for multiple systems.
The pattern is the same as it
was for classical information.
We can view multiple quantum systems as single compound systems and apply what we know
from the previous lesson.
Again, tensor products
will play a key role and overall we obtain a description for how quantum information
works for multiple systems.
That's very much analogous
and mathematically similar to what we just saw for
classical information.
We'll start with quantum states.
Quantum states of multiple systems are represented by column vectors having complex number entries
and Euclid arm equal to one
just like quantum states
of single systems.
This time the indices of
the quantum state vectors correspond to the Cartesian product of the classical state sets
of the individual systems
because again, that is
the classical state set of the compound system.
For example, if X and Y or Qubits, then the classical state
set for the par XY together is the Cartesian product of the
binary alphabet with itself,
which we can think about as
the set up all binary strings of length two.
So these vectors that you see here are all examples of quantum
state vectors of XY.
If we want to, we can alternatively write
these vectors like this where we have a separate
cat for each Qubit
where the tensor product
between them is implicit.
Or we can also write the
tensor product symbol explicitly like this if you prefer.
And another option is
to subscript the cats with the names of the systems
that they represent like this.
And you can do this with
the tensor product symbol or without.
That can sometimes be very helpful for keeping things straight.
These are just different styles for expressing the same vectors and we can pick whichever one we want or whichever we prefer or
whichever makes the most sense
for the situation at hand. When things get more
complicated for instance, we might decide that one of
these styles adds clarity
and we're free to make
whichever choice we want.
Tensor products of quantum state vectors are also quantum state vectors.
For the case of two systems for instance, if Phi is a quantum state
vector of a system X and Psi is a quantum state
vector of a system Y,
then the tensor product of Phi and Psi is a quantum state vector of XY.
We call states like this product states and similar to what we saw in the classical probabilistic setting, they represent independence
between the systems X and Y.
So for instance, if one person has a laboratory
in one part of the world and they create a system X and initialize it to the quorum state Phi
and another person in
another part of the world independently initializes a system Y to the quantum state Psi,
then if we choose to think about XY as forming a single system even though it's two parts or in different parts of the world,
then the compound system XY is
in the state Phi tensor Psi.
This all generalizes to
more than two systems in the natural way.
If we have quantum
states Psi1 through PsiN of separate systems Xn through Xn, then the tensor product of these n vectors
represents a quantum state, which is again called a product state of the compound system X1 through Xn.
Here's an example of a
quantum state of two Qubits.
Although it might not
look like it immediately. It is an example of a product state because we can write
it as a tensor product as you see right here.
So it's an example of a
product state regardless of how it's written, what's relevant is whether
or not it's possible to write it as a tensor product.
This quantum state, however, which is again a state of two
Qubits is not a product state.
It's similar in spirit to
the example that we saw in the probabilistic setting of two perfectly correlated random bits
and the same argument reveals that it can't be written
as a tensor product.
So let's move this over here and let's take a look at the argument in a little bit more detail.
Let's imagine that we
could write this state as a tensor product of
two vectors Phi and Psi.
The entry corresponding
to the classical state 0,1 is zero for this vector, which we can see just by looking at it.
This would imply however, if the vector was a tensor
product of two vectors that the zero entry of Phi
times the one entry of Psi
would be equal to zero, but that means that either
the zero entry of Phi or the one entry of Psi is equal to zero
or they both could be equal to zero, but that contradicts the fact
that these two products here must both be non-zero.